very good uh okay yeah thank you very
much for uh the invitation thank you
very much for calling me
uh yeah i'm sure that we have already
heard a lot of great talks in this
workshop so today i'm going to talk
about something very simple
as usual okay so i'm going to talk about
non-stochastic multiplayer material
bandits
and this is a growing work with sag
marcanua
okay so what is marty armbandy problem
i'm sure
like everybody here knows what is
material but it is just a very simple
model to make
to model how to make sequential
decisions online
okay so there are all these arms and
then there's a player
okay so uh just to introduce some
notation we assume that there are k arms
and then there are t
rungs so at each round t the player will
pick a specific
action from these k arms and they need
to observe a reward
from zero to one okay so observe some
bounded reward
and of course the goal of the player is
just to maximize the accumulated reward
in this very simple material bandit
problem okay
so uh today i'm going to talk about a
slightly different question which is
what if there are multiple players
playing in the same environment
okay so in standard material money there
is just one single player
who makes the action that's very rigid
but what if there are multiple players
and making decisions at the same time
in particular in the same environment
okay so what if there are two players
like this
and they both have the uh the same side
of
arms okay and they want to pick action
simultaneously
okay so the central issue is that
typically
i mean when you have this setting and
you have rewards on each arm
and typically when two players pick the
same action at the same rung
they are only being able to get one
piece of reward in total
or even worse they will get even fewer
reward due to a completion
okay just think of i mean just think of
buying some lottery okay that
if the two players bought the same
lottery number then of course they are
going to share
the reward okay so there's no two
uh pieces of the reward it's only one
single piece
okay just to say mathematically
when player a picks an arc action a t
and player b
picks an action bt and when a t and b t
is equal to
the same action so we'll only be able to
get a total reward
r t of a instead of the summation of
these two
okay if they pick different arms then of
course they can collect
uh the overall rewards but if they pick
the same arm
okay they only get one piece of reward
or even worse
okay so what is the
uh motivation of this environment the
first motivation is the cognitive radio
networks
and this is actually the first uh this
is actually where
the multiplayer material bandit was
first introduced
okay it's just to model the cognitive
radio networks
okay there are in these networks there
are a lot of users like
user one user two user three okay and
they want to sign some radio
okay and then there are some underlying
channels maybe like a hundred channels
okay and the users want to sign their
signals
through some channel okay
and the point is some channels are
faster some are slower
and the users say they are greedy they
want to use the fastest
or the best channel and use it okay
but the problem is if two users rush to
the same channel at the same time
they both get delayed okay and maybe
just because there is even a collision
they cannot even sign the message
okay so not only they are not getting
the rewards they are actually getting
punished
if there is a creation okay
so basically the central issue here is
instead of the
one player setting if you have
multiplayers
the players have to learn the players
are greedy
they want to figure out which channels
are better
but then there are also competitions
among the players
okay if all the players are very greedy
then they may just rush to the leading
channel and
it all gets delayed okay so it's
uh basically the challenge here is
fundamentally different from
single player setting okay in
single-player setting you just want to
selfishly maximize your reward but here
if everybody just selfishly maximize
their own reward
they may actually become very bad okay
just because they rush to the leading
channel and they all get
punished okay so in particular
here i mean the players they want to
they want to learn what is the best
channel but they also want to
kind of collaborate to distribute their
actions
across different channels okay and also
another motivation is this is the most
preliminary framework to study
multi-agent learning system
okay so imagine asian learning system of
course the collaboration is the key
okay how does these learners collaborate
while they are learning
and here you can see that they
definitely need to collaborate
in order to avoid rushing to the same
arm at the same iteration
okay
so basically uh here is a multiplayer
material bundy setting and we see
that the main difficulty here is the
competition
okay the players wants to avoid
picking the same action at the same time
okay so this is the most basic model for
collaboration
of course you can think of other models
where
like for example picking the same arm is
actually encouraged but
that's out of the scope of this work
okay so we consider the most basic
setting
where in this setting to maximize the
total accumulated reward
among all the players it is important
that
all the players pick the different
actions at the same run
okay so the players if the two players
pick the same action at the same run
they will
always get a worse reward comparing to
you say pick different actions
okay so basically picking the same
picking different actions is the key
here
to maximize the reward okay
so basically if the players do pick
different
actions like the same round we call this
a no collision strategy
okay so no player speaks the same action
at the same iteration
okay then there is no creation so we
call this a no cliche
strategy and we define the associate's
no
cliche strategy or the regret for the no
cliche strategy
for the m players mighty our multiplayer
material bandit
is essentially the maximal actions that
the player can
do on the hindsight miners like whatever
the players
actually achieve in the in the entire
game
okay so here a t of i is the actual
player i
is time t okay and we
assume that there is no collision so a t
of i
is not equal to a t of j for every
player i
and j that are not equal okay so at the
same
time each player has to pick different
arms
okay so we call this a no creation
strategy so the players have to
distribute
their uh their their peaks along
different arms
okay and also they want to maximize the
total accumulated reward
so basically they want to learn okay
they want to learn in this
in this environment to maximize the
reward and also they want to collaborate
okay so there are just two goals in
multiplayer mighty armbanded
okay there there's the goal of learning
and then there's
the goal of collaboration to avoid
collision
okay so that's a problem that we are we
study in this work
okay and the central question is can we
get low regret algorithm without
collisions okay that's a question we ask
in this work
and we will give some answer for this
question okay
okay cool so basically just to
illustrate there might be some very
simple strategy to get
uh low rib uh to get low
low regret without any collision okay so
this is a very simple strategy assuming
that you have a central server
and the central server is going to
select a subset of size
m using for example multiplicative way
to update
a direct region and then they just
communicate with the players about these
side eyes
as he and the players just take actions
in i see
okay so players distribute the actions
they communicate and to avoid collisions
and then they just communicate back the
reward to the server
okay so there's very simple strategy to
achieve low regret
okay so just to achieve low regret and
collaboration itself
is very very simple okay but what is
wrong with this simple strategy well the
symbol strategy has a main
problem which is a strategy actually
requires the player to communicate at
every iteration
okay so the players essentially they
need to sit in the same room
or they're in the same zoom call in
order to communicate
okay and they need to communicate at
every iteration
because they need to collaborate at
every iteration to avoid creation
okay so basically using this simple
strategy you have low rig right you'll
have no collision
but the total b is of communication is
omega of t
okay but the communication cost is very
high
okay just like in the cognitive radio
network the goal is to communicate
and if the players they can communicate
then why
why do they need cognitive radio
networks at all
okay so the entire goal is to to
communicate for these applications so
the communication cost
is something you don't want to pay okay
so basically uh that's motivates the uh
the real problem that considered in our
work which is
can we actually get a low regret
algorithm without collision and with
very
limited communication cost or rather
there's no communication cost at all
okay so can you still have low rate
right
can you still have low regret and no
cliche
and minimize the amount of communication
okay so you don't want to communicate
with others to collaborate at every
equation
in that way although you can get no
cliche you can't have low regret
but the communication cost is very high
okay just impractical
in those applications like the age
device
or all these multi-agent learning system
i mean you have
all these age device distributed across
the world
of course the communication cost is the
real budget
okay so just to say the communication
cost is very high okay the
communication is money that we don't
want to pay
okay so basically the central question
we ask in our work is that can we get
low regret algorithm without collision
and with smaller amounts of
communication cost
okay so the player wants to learn and
the players want to
collaborate but they don't want to
communicate okay
so how do the players learn and
collaborate
without communication that's what we are
going to study in
this work okay
so also just a note that we we assume
that we have we need to implement a
strategy without
any cliche okay this is actually a
stronger version
of the setting where players can collide
but there is no cliche information okay
so the players get punished when there
is a collision but they don't know
whether the low reward is due to a
collision or just this arm is bad
okay so maybe two player rush to the to
the same arm and then they both get
delayed but they don't know if the delay
is due to a collision
or it's due to there is another player
okay
so of course in our setting this is our
setting is
it's a stronger version than that
because we have no cliche at all
okay so the players doesn't even collide
so even if you have no cliche
information it doesn't
affect me because i have no cliche okay
and our setting implies no regret
algorithm there is when there is no
cliche information but the players can't
collide
because in our setting the players don't
even climb okay so it's a stronger
version
and also our setting implies low regret
no communication algorithm when there is
collision information
because our algorithm has no collision
so you can actually use the cliche
information to communicate okay
because the original algorithm has no
collision so the
additional cliche must be due to some
communication protocol
that is implemented on top of our
algorithm
okay so just to say our setting is
general and it implies
all these versions that you may consider
in practice but our setting
is the most general one okay
so what is the prior works in this
setting well the
most of the prior works focus on the
case when there is stochastic setting
even the reward of each rmit iteration t
follows from the same distribution
okay so the environments are not
changing over time
it just you'll get some stochastic
observation and every iteration
but the stochastic remains the same okay
there are
a bunch of works you can see the
citation in our paper but
not going to elaborate that so all of
them focus on the stochastic setting
and but just to say in multiplayer
material bundy settings such as
cognitive radio networks the underlying
environment
is obviously changing over time okay so
it's affected by the weather by the
electrical condition or some other like
magnetic conditions
whatever it's definitely changing over
time okay
so the channels just maybe come faster
or slower at different times
they are not stationary okay they are
actually changing over time and you
really want to
learn uh from these changing
environments
okay so in our work we actually focus on
the harder
non-stationary setting also known as
oblivious adversarial
set okay so this underlying environment
is definitely changing over time okay
and the non-stationary setting is
fundamentally different from stationary
sighting due to the fundamental dilemma
okay so for non-stationary material
bundy setting even for a single player
it is known that the player has to
constantly performing
exploration and cannot stick to some
fixed action
okay just like in this feature the
player has to switch
arm very frequently non-stationary
setting because the environment is
changing over time
if it stays at a fixer then it cannot
adapt to the changing environment
okay so it's not like in stationary
environments when you identify a subset
of base arms then you can stay there
okay in non-stationary
environment you cannot play something
stationary
you have to change actions very
frequently
but i know there is a fundamental
difficulty which is a player if the
players do not communicate
so how do they collaborate to make sure
that there's no cliche
if they are all changing rapidly and
they have no communication
okay then how do they even collaborate
okay
so in particular in fact by the seminal
work by over deco at all
it is known that in non-stationary
material bandits
omega t switches is necessary to obtain
root t regret
okay so obtain the traditional root t
regret
you need omega t switches okay so
it's it's non-stationary at all you have
to constantly
switch okay so it's not even like t to
the two thirds which is
it's like to obtain root t optimal
regret you have to switch almost every
iteration
okay just a non-stationary hypo
okay or t to the two thirds which is
necessary to obtain the t to the two
third regret
okay so just to say in non-steroidal
resetting switching is necessary
okay you have to make constant switches
so
i mean then there is the fundamental
challenge that is
all the players are switching and they
don't communicate how do they avoid
collision
i mean they are all switching at every
iteration
and they don't communicate who knows who
goes to where
okay so it seems like to avoid collision
and to obtain
order of routine regret omega tb
self-communication
is necessary between the players he just
by these seminal results
you have to switch at almost every
iteration and since there are multiple
players
you have to know like whether player a
goes through that arm or not
and player a's are switching like
breezies so you must
be able to do that okay so this sounds
like you must
communicate omega tb self information
okay so that's why the preliminary works
all focus
on stationary setting because people
don't even believe
that in non-stationary setting less than
less than other key communication is
possible
okay just by this result okay
intuitively it doesn't sound like it's
possible
okay but actually in this work we show
the following result
that is there is an efficient root t
regret algorithm without collision
and with only root t b sub total
communication
okay so you can actually reduce the
communication cost from t
to root t okay and moreover there is an
efficient t to the two thirds
regret algorithm without cliche and
without any communication
okay so you can still get low regret
algorithm even without any click
communication without any collision okay
so you have no information from other
players
at all okay so even if you have uh
so even if i mean even if you are able
to have some clinician
information i mean in our settings there
isn't even no collision
at all between the players okay so they
don't even communicate
at all okay but still low regret is
possible
okay so that's our work
and in the remaining uh two minutes we
show you the
idea of the algorithm in the two-player
case okay there's player step
and then there's player mark okay
player wants to say something so the
main idea for the first result is that
sev will use a low speeching strategy
is not going to say anything
yes i have a question i mean not the
question but just
can you say something about shared
randomness
just so that because otherwise it's
really really mystifying
uh yeah yeah i'm going to say that later
okay all right yeah so basically
what happened is that the player said
set it will
uses a low switching strategy that only
swedish arms
approximately every routine delicious
okay
so basically what happens is when that
player saps which is the arm he is going
to tell player mark
which arm he is going to pick okay
and then the player mark plays on the
remaining set of arms and obviously
there will be no collision because
player
mark knows which arm player service
stays on the remaining set alarms okay
so the player step uses a low switching
strategy
and of course only root t b sub
communication is needed because the
only switch arms approximately every
routine iteration
okay so only root t b self communication
is needed because they only
switch on routine times okay so just
like
in this setting in the player's side you
know player 7 is a boss so he stays
constant
and player mark is the inter so he do
does the
exploration on the remaining side of
arms
okay but so here this just naive
implementation of this strategy has a
pretty big problem which is if player
set uses a low switching strategy that
only switch arms approximately routine
how does he know which arm is good i
mean as we have seen in the
non-stationary setting
like t switches is necessary to achieve
rooty regret
but sav only switch arms routine times
so obviously like uh if if there's seven
alone he cannot
really achieve rooty regret okay so how
does he have enough exploration on the
other arms okay then here is our very
simple idea
that is player mark actually does
exploration on the remaining set of arms
okay so when player 7 decides to switch
arm play mark is going to tell seb about
the estimated accumulated reward
on all the other arms okay so basically
a player said when a player play mark
doesn't play on the
purple arm so player 7 is going to tell
player mark the reward of the purple arm
and player mark is going to tell players
step
the accumulated or estimated accumulated
reward on all the other arms
hey so basically
in this in this case i mean they both
have
sufficient observation and they can
actually achieve
uh rooty regret with only rooty piece of
communication
okay so basically this algorithm is very
simple okay
it's a very easy algorithm okay and uh
so basically with root t b self
communication is pretty easy
okay and also with through tb self
self-communication you can also
use your random generator to send shared
random
screens okay that's not a problem but
what if
you want to maybe maybe just for the
experts in the room we should tell them
that
the the variance calculation is not as
easy as you make it sound and
there is i mean it's not that easy like
yeah i mean the exact uh result is not
that easy but
i mean the spirit is very easy so that
is very
easy in my standard okay so
basically this is this is not hard to
imagine that this is doable although the
detailed implementation may
be a bit tricky but it's this imaginable
that is easy
okay but what if the players
cannot pass any information okay what if
there's no communication at all
so they cannot exchange their history
and they cannot
know where the players lies in each
iteration
okay so what if there's no communication
at all in this case even seth is playing
a low speeching strategy
he cannot tell player mark which arm he
lands
okay so what's what can we do in this
setting
it sounds like in this settings the
challenge is fundamentally different
and it sounds like low regret is very
hard
okay because i mean even sab is
switching
very slowly player mark doesn't know
which charm set
lines okay and of course there's no
collision at all so
it's very very tricky okay
so we will actually show that they can
still achieve t to the two third regret
without
any communication okay so they can
collaborate
without communicating of course in this
setting we assume that they have some
shared random source
okay so they are they can have access to
some shared random screen
that is shared there okay it's a it's
like shared in the public it's like they
have
the religion i mean they maybe have some
of the reason of the current time
okay and then they can use this as seeds
to generate pseudo-random strings
okay so they have some shared like
pseudo-random source
okay that's our assumption okay
so let's just illustrate the algorithm
in the two-player setting again player 7
player mark okay so the main
installation is uh the following thought
experiment
is that what if we are actually in the
full information setting
well in this setting the player mark and
player 7 can actually use the
follow the perturb leader strategy okay
using a shared random permutation
okay so what would they do is that the
player seven player arm can agree on a
prescribed order
before the game begin which is like
player 7 is a ball so he always
picks the best arm okay after
perturbation
and player mark always picks a second
best arm okay after perturbation
and the key observation is that in full
information setting seven mark
observes the same reward sequence so
they have no clinician because they
agree on what is the best for the
turbine
and the second best for turnover okay so
they will
always agree and they will always have
no collision
and they will actually have low regret
because
follow the perturb leader works in this
setting
okay so it's very simple if you are
actually at full
information setting with a shared random
screen stream then you don't
need communication okay just
just like uh just i mean use this
prescribed order and then the player
seven
the arm kind of work collision while
achieving low regret
okay but here the main difficulty is
what
they are actually in bandit setting in
our case
okay they are only having partial
observations
and also their observations must be
different due to no collision
because it cannot even observe the
reward in the same armament the same
iteration
and so their law sequence must be
completely different
okay so in this setting
actually i mean since i'm running out of
time
i'm going to sketch it very fast okay so
in this setting actually
what you can do is you can suffer or
regret
t to the two thirds to make sure that
you lost estimator of
player sub and player mark only differs
by a factor of t to the two third okay
so basically you suffer from a sufferer
regret of t to the two thirds
just by exploration at a fixed rate t to
the minus one third
okay and then by some simple
concentration bond you can make sure
that the reward estimators are always
different by just a factor of t to the
two thirds
okay so basically now the question is
can we make sure i mean if we are
willing to pay a
regret of t to the two thirds can we
actually make sure that the players have
no collision about their loss estimator
or their reward estimators
differ just by a factor of t to the two
third
okay so you may think maybe i can still
use follow the project either that's not
true
and follow the perturb leader will be
horrible in this case
even if you have even if your wish will
suffer a regret of t to the two third
the perturbation will be of size t to
the 2 3
okay but the estimator also just divided
by t to the two thirds so you may have
constant collisions okay so you have you
may have very high chance to collide
if you use follow the perturb lead okay
so what we are actually going to do is
the so-called follow the software term
leader
okay which is uh something like
essentially you assign the probability
to each
action that you want so essentially you
have you want to simulate the central
server
uh scenario where the central server has
a joint probability on
the both actions it's the actions that
are different
and they want they want to simulate the
central strategy on their end
okay so what happens is that they will
compute
something like a probability of peaking
arm a
which defines in this formula okay
and the main observation is that if the
player can pick
arms according to this margin
probability and without
any collision then this is a low regret
algorithm
okay because p a b times l a plus l b
is actually equal to p a times l t of a
okay so this is a low regret algorithm
if you can
two players can keep the margin
probability and avoid collision
okay so how do the two players keep the
margin probability to kind of weight
collision
well they just pull the probability on a
circle
okay so they just put probability one on
the
circle of arm one on the circle
probability of arm 2 on the circle
okay and the player 7 is going to pick
uh the action according to a random
variable s
and in this case set will go into p arm
2
and mark is going to peak according to
the arm that is pointing by negative
s okay so is a negative eyes on two
sides of the circle
okay so uh basically it's the main
observation in this case is that
actually every probability has when it's
smaller or equal to a half
okay if you have a cliche it seems it
must be like some probability
has weight close to a half so they both
lie in the same probability
okay and also they are kind of leaches
okay
so in this setting they can actually
avoid collision
okay so this is a strategy there is a
location strategy and the players
can actually avoid collision using some
shared randomness
okay and just at the end we say we
mention open problems that is can we
have low regret algorithm
without collision information without
collisions
without communication and without shared
randomness okay just without anything
can we get a low regret algorithm
and we believe that this is impossible
unless the reward is zero one and you
have
you get zero when there is a creation
okay so you have semi information
because you know
when you get reward once there is no
collision and we do know how to solve
the problem without collision
without collision uh information without
communication without shared randomness
in this case
but in general we conjecture this is
impossible
okay and that's the end of my talk
thanks thank you andrew and do we have a
quick question i have a question
i'm just trying to understand the circle
the two circles that you drew
i didn't quite catch that argument over
there so
actually this this is a an excellent
question but the answer is not
that easy so i think this will be a
perfect topic for the discussion
uh so maybe let's keep that question of
re-explaining what's happening with the
circles to the to the discussion i think
it's a very good question but it will
take more than one minute to answer
um okay let's move on to the next talk
and then we can ask